[Music]
[Applause]
Ramona Shelburne ESPN NBA Insider senior
writer NBA today panelist how much
trouble are the Lakers in Ramona
they're okay for now like they you know
I thought they could have
they should have won game two and did
not right so how do you you know it's
one thing if you're getting blown out of
these games if you're not competitive if
you don't match up well with this team I
think Denver looks like a better team in
these two games but the Lakers are right
there with them and how much of the way
Denver looks is because you know you're
playing at altitude the Lakers kind of
hit a wall I think they're playing
LeBron and A.D and some of their main
guys really heavy minutes early on and I
thought in the in the fourth quarter
last night let's just looked like the
Lakers hit a wall it just got they look
tired
um it was a lot to ask LeBron to be
guarding nickel yokic and trying to be
LeBron on offense but they go back home
they haven't lost at home since late
March they have lots of game there in a
long time
um you gotta feel good about that
they've gotten pretty much nothing out
of D'Angelo Russell in this series he'll
probably play better at home they
haven't got much from Dennis or he'll
probably play any better at home but I
don't think they're in that much trouble
yet yeah I was watching last night and
LeBron's settling for those three-point
shots and this happens a lot with older
players that they will settle because it
you know it takes a lot to get to the
hoop and LeBron when he gets to the hoop
is the you know one of the maybe the
best clothes that we've ever seen but he
keeps shooting the threes and the
Nuggets wanting to keep shooting the
threes for somebody with a really high
basketball IQ at what point does LeBron
say you know what maybe I shouldn't be
taking these threes he's the greatest
scorer of all time he's nowhere near one
of the greatest Shooters of all time
yeah it's a good good way to put it um
he uh you know you've seen the graphic
right or the the stats of you know he's
what he is by quarter for for three
pointers in the playoffs and it's it's
pretty sad right they had water 20 in
the third in the whole playoffs
um and every time I I see him shoot it
I'm like I'm like yelling at the TV oh I
gotta get what do you do you know I mean
they're daring him to shoot those shots
that's that's what they're giving him
and I you know I think he makes the
change I mean he he he will try to shoot
himself through some of these things
he's he um he's not afraid of taking
those shots but after I think he is
smart enough to say okay you know
they're daring me to take them we have
to do something else here
um Anthony Davis was the same thing I
thought
he hasn't been a good three-point
shooter the last few years he really had
like and he made one of them yesterday
and it was like oh is this gonna come
back because if you remember in 2020 one
of the biggest shots of Anthony Davis's
career was when he hit the three against
the nuggets and then yelled out Kobe you
remember that and that was like this
very defining moment for him and I felt
like when he hit the first one I was
like oh we're back in 2020 where he's
making threes again I I mean he if he
hits those shots there it really gives a
different dimension to the Laker offense
but he hasn't he really hasn't hit three
pointers in a couple years so you know
they at some point you kind of have to
get realistic with what you're really
going to do offensively and I I think
that I think the adjustment for the
Lakers is to find some way to get
production out of some of their other
good offensive players who have done
things in the playoffs who should be
able to do things in this series they've
got they can't just ask as much of
LeBron and AZ on both ends of the court
and also there's so much focus on
stopping or at least containing Joker
that Jamal Murray is averaging seven
more points per game in the playoffs uh
how much of a responsibility is that
going to be because he looked like you
know the second coming at Klay Thompson
last night in the fourth quarter
it wasn't that amazing stat somebody
came up with last night
um he's got four 20-point quarters 20
point fourth quarters and that the only
other that's the most in the last like
25 years the other or I ever said in
Jordan wow that's pretty good yeah yeah
I mean he's he's Jamal is that heat
check kind of guy he he was that guy in
the bubble he we just we don't think of
him that way because he hasn't been an
All-Star he he play maybe that's where
Michael Malone is right about about them
not getting the national attention or
whatever it is you know I I heard some
of that laugh I just thought that was
coach talk tried to fire this team up
and making sure they knew that no one's
respecting them and they have their own
respect
um you know my my second thought on that
was uh you know be careful what you wish
for
you want all the attention Okay
at all and and I I was saying that to
nuggets fans this morning like you know
what it's okay like the last three years
we've waited for you to take the next
step San Antonio Spurs never ask for any
publicity their head coach did their
star player didn't all they said is if
we win a championship you have to cover
us you have to talk about it and that's
what I would say to Denver just win yeah
right yeah I mean listen I I feel like I
have done so many segments on NBA today
where we will react to a Denver Nuggets
game or highlight and I'm pretty sure my
my analysis Richard Jefferson's met all
of us we all go hey that that nickel
joke is man is he good
all right next next topic next topic
yeah right uh yeah I mean I think we've
been saying that for four years I I also
wanted to bring this up that uh on
Monday Ramona reported that James
Harden's potential free agency might
hinge on whether or not the Sixers
brought Doc Rivers back for another
season
well we saw how that played out are the
Sixers guaranteed that James Harden is
coming back after firing Doc Rivers
I think they're guaranteed of that and I
um
you know it's a it's an interesting
dilemma for them because on the one hand
they cannot afford to lose James Hardy
because if he leaves they don't have
very much to replace him they don't have
any of those mechanisms in the salary
under the salary cap to replace them you
just walk out the door and I think the
Houston situation is a real threat and I
think other teams maybe Phoenix who are
looking for an offensive player like
that
um those are those are real threats to
watch with heart and he can you know
probably make the most money in
Philadelphia for the longest term but
Houston is they do have a significant
amount of cash space and they really
could could resign him which is a fun
full circle after the way he laughed
right
um but uh you know I I think
you know the way I phrased it on the
show and I think this is the right way
to put it is it would be hard to see
James coming back if doc was still the
coach does that mean he went in there
and said I'm leaving if Doc is here no
it means that everybody knew they didn't
have a great relationship right that
there had been some um you know it was
it was a doctor kind of got into James a
few times you know trying to do with
this culture of accountability he has he
tries to have in his in his locker room
and uh no he's go over well right and I
think the offensive system I think James
never felt quite comfortable
um playing a different role he was
really his role was really supposed to
be in service to embiid and he talked
very openly very often about having to
sacrifice his authenticity for Joelle
um so I think that was that's it's all
of the above I think James is smart
enough to realize you know he didn't
have to say it like that and for people
to understand what his feelings were but
they used to have some work to do to
resign him and now the question is
are they a better team with James Harden
long term are they do they want to
commit to this bead-hearted marriage for
the next four years because that's what
it would be yeah um and you know or can
you risk letting him walk out the door
are there things you could do with sign
and trades it's uh you know I think
Daryl Moore phrased it well he said you
know option one is to recite James
option two is to get really creative uh
you know I I don't I don't know what's
which option is better
uh thanks for joining us thanks for
getting up and uh we appreciate your
time as always does is this more likely
to be a five game series with the Lakers
or a seven game series
yeah we have to we
listen to play us where we go from one
game to the next and I mean from what
you've seen what do you think I think it
looks like the Lakers were in both games
they shouldn't have won game one they
were lucky to be there in two they
should have won and they kind of blew it
at the end and Jamal Murray got hot like
that's a pretty good you should have got
one of those games in Denver but at some
point you have to hold serve at home and
and they've been really good at home
it's been for two months thank you
Ramona
got it Dan that's Ramona Shelburne ESPN
NBA Insider senior writer works for uh
NBA today